bibi piep wir haben uns alle lieb
was machst du jähriger wir haben noch
die partikel die ramblers michael du
machst du leute was was geht wartet
leute bevor jetzt ein display gibt so
bei seinem video oder meinen also bei
meinen wahrscheinlich er gerade weil ich
guck mal ich bin halt wir haben halt ab
so ja genau bevor wir mit der richtigen
auflösung anfangen wollte noch bezahlen
bei ihm gibt es noch weitere erklärungen
staat es einfach nach dem video an ganz
unbescheiden danzinger video
beschreibung viel spaß
schaut euch das video in ruhe an und
trinkt vielleicht aber ein täter mit der
ganzen scheiße hätte ich die bibel
wir haben uns alle ich weiß gar nicht
wie ich anfangen soll also das ist halt
angefangen so wir haben uns gedacht so
ja auf youtube dass ich wir haben auch
ein beweis zeige ich euch gleich alles
gut wir haben damit gestern haben wir so
gedacht wir setzen jetzt die idee
einfach so umgeht in die tat um
aber vor allem ich habe niemals damit
gerechnet dass ich so hoch genommen
werde so von allen so weil ich halt dumm
bin ich hab halt eingefallen weil ich so
und warum macht man sowas öffentlich und
ich werde dieses hoch genommen so er
selbst verleiht zuschauern werde ich
hochgenommen ehrlich und ja auf jeden
fall wir waren gestern halt haben fifa
gezeugt haben wir machen das man einfach
mit diesem mit diesem befund nehmen im
hintergrund auf das wir uns halt
bisschen so darüber witzig machen dass
eine seite ihn vielleicht eine mich
eigentlich sollte noch jemand dazu
kommen weil nicht zu vergessen leute vor
allem der hintergrund dieser ganze sache
ist so ein biest schon mal alle wissen
jetzt wer und was um die wohl gemeint
ist wir wollen euch dann zeigen heute
nur youtuber sind eine gewisse
reichweite haben
vor allem das war auch noch so gewinnen
wollen euch zeit leute das miteinander
was sagt dass ihr das nicht glauben soll
zum beispiel er hat sein video
hochgeladen und alle kommen direkt auf
mich drauf hast ja durch rufen so du buy
und dann kam ein video online und zwar
alle gehen auf ihr rüber warum heißt das
öffentlich keine ahnung wir haben hier
immer kurzen ausschnitt von gestern
waren gestern heute morgen noch um zwei
war mir zusammen essen und haben da halt
kurz gefilmt wie wir das machen wollen
zeig ich euch mal da ist auch dabei ist
21 das wetter morgen
hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video
es ist gerade zu kurz es ist gerade 26
und wir haben den braucht man kurz abend
hier 26
und wir haben den einmaligen zwanzigsten
sechs 2016
wir haben uns gedacht werden das schon
länger im kopf so dass wir einfach mal
sondern wirklich social experiment
machen so cool auf englisch gesagt und
zwar wir sind gerade essen wir hatten
noch hunger so besprechen das gerade
ganz gechillt auf jeden fall wollen wir
einfach so ich finde es ganz ähnlich
schade so das ding ist halt was was mir
so auffällt so egal was youtuber sagen
die können sonne scheiß erzählen keiner
hinterfragt das wirklich nur die
wenigsten hinterfragen irgendwelche
aussagen von youtube irgendwelche kassen
aussagen und nehmen das einfach so in
das stimmt und das ist vielleicht in 50
prozent der fälle der fall so aber das
volk angekommen
aber meistens ist es halt
spaß gegen eine kacke die sich irgendwie
erfunden hat oder sonst was
und wir wollen halt mal mit so ein
bisschen wie ich mäßig auf was
aufmerksam machen auf der einen seite
das ding ist wir wollen euch einfach nur
unterhalten so das ist unterhaltung
deswegen uns ganz gezielt auf der einen
seite kannst natürlich bisschen sie
rüber kommen wenn man so etwas macht auf
der anderen seite seit lässt sich drauf
ist doch witzig oder nicht ihr habt
unterhalten und freunde wer mit diesem
brief anfang
miguel mit einem echten leben
geschrieben was habt ihr vorgänger kam
auf bevor du das machst und vergiss
nicht dass wieder zudrehen gesagt dass
alles gespielt ist das machen wir gerade
jetzt noch einmal die geilen
wir haben auf jeden fall eben kiefer
gezweifelt haben die ganze zeit so uns
kaputtgelacht zum irgendwelchen theorien
wieder so ausgeht
und jetzt eben ich nehme jetzt gleich
ein video auf oder neben das video bei
mir auch hoffentlich auch in münchen
nicht für mich schon ein bisschen als
sie aber irgendwie mein gott er hat
jeden tag video was euch hoffentlich
unterhält
irgendwie sind einfach die einzigen
kongresses egal was wir wollen euch
sagen ihr sollt nicht auf jeden youtuber
glauben in der scheiße labert deswegen
wir wollen euch zeigen dass nicht mit
irgendeiner was klar was ist es die
rechte weil er direkt ein video gemacht
hat okay leute herzlich willkommen
zurück
auf jeden fall ich hab dann wirklich so
als ich das öffentlich gemacht habe
hatte ich auch schon so ehrlich ich
hatte schon hab schon discs bekommen
sich als 1000 likes hatte doch 200 bis
gleich wieder soweit ich zeitweilig so
etwas öffentlich mache so ist klar und
dann ging aber auch so viele zu ihm und
haben ihn wirklich so bleibst du selbst
selbst wenn man das macht wenn es
release das kippt euch doch nicht die
begründung selbst okay es kommt
vielleicht ein bisschen doof zu aber wir
wollen euch nur zeigen deutsche glaubt
nicht alles wir haben es jetzt auch
sofort aufgelöst so meine freunde ist zu
mir gekommen die hat gesagt er ganz
ehrlich so was will ich nicht so wir
hätten ich hatte hier noch mal kurz auch
schon habe ich gerade gedreht ich hätte
wirklich niemals gedacht dass es so das
ist so krass polarisiert ehrlich das ist
nicht ein video in meinem einer
kompletten youtube laufbahn hat so viele
klicks gemacht heftig vor allem leute
ohne scheiß ich weiß ich sage online bot
diese clique [ __ ] oder sonst
irgendwas wir wollen euch aber damit
zeigen nur weil wir eine reichweite
haben solltet ihr uns nicht direkt
glauben wenn ihr eine sache nicht wisst
man kann es natürlich auf der einen
seite so ansehen als wenn wir gern
klicks waren so klar wollen wir gerne
klick machen wir wollen euch unterhalten
aber sicher auf der anderen seite
einfach so wir wollten mal was
ausprobieren und werden wir übrigens
klick geld dann würde keiner von uns
jetzt irgendwas öffentlich machen wir
laden das jetzt heute lösen das direkt
am gleichen tag um 21 uhr haupt oder so
weil es wirklich krass durch die
geldsäcke geht das will keiner von uns
beiden
und ja keine ahnung also
ehrlich noch mal von uns beiden so wir
mögen uns und wir würden uns wenn wir
wie farben dann klären wir das nicht im
internet für die zukunft wenn sich zwei
streiten dann wollen sie einfach nur
klicks haben und abos generieren nur
deswegen machen sie dann diesen brief
öffentlich so wie wir gerade eigentlich
seniorin aber leuchtet schild alles gut
ist kommt nicht wieder vor
es sollte ehrlich nur so ein kleines
experiment werden aber euch einlassen
wolle was eine woche geht
wir wollen jetzt auch vielleicht von
euch so das geht jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen an die jüngeren weil es war
auch echt viele dabei die haben es
gezeigt sohn gesagt ihr glaubt dass
nicht alles so aber vielleicht an die
jüngeren die auch viel auf youtube
unterwegs sind glaubt 50 prozent von dem
was es euch gesagt nicht mal nicht mag
ich nicht weil ich es ist einfach so
viel nicht real
ich hoffe ihr nehmt das jetzt so auf und
hält uns jetzt nicht beide grundlos oder
so was heißt grundlos ist es schon ein
kleiner anstoß so ein junger lehrer ein
junger lehrer meinte matsui miami herald
war glaube ich eine chance verdient nein
nein nicht das glaubt nicht alles was du
hörst glaubt nur das was du siehst denn
genau das was du siehst ist nicht das
was du hörst das geld ich habe noch hier
bei ihnen gependelt
ich habe noch ein café gegeben damit er
schnell wird auf jeden fall wenn wenn
ihr auf unserer seite steht könnt ihr
gerne daumen nach oben da lassen wenn
nicht wenn ihr wenn wir wenn wir jetzt
endgültig verkauft haben
island ist ein bisschen leid so auch
aber was wir wollen den quasi die zahlen
dass sie nicht als bloggen sollen ja es
geht ja auch nur vielleicht können sich
jetzt welche damit auch ein bisschen
falsch angesprochen das wollen wir auch
nicht nur an die leute die wirklich
alles glauben so schild nimmt das jetzt
als gut gemeinte kritik an
ich nehme auch oft kritik an vielleicht
nicht immer so gut gebe ich offen zu
manchmal habe ich vielleicht das ein
oder andere mal übertrieben klar kann
sein er auch es passiert jeder macht
fehler
ja leute genau und vergesst nicht bei
ihm vorbei zu schauen damit noch ein
bisschen weiter auf
ganz oben in der video beschreibung
verlinkt und ja danke fürs anschauen wie
gesagt ich habe euch alle trotzdem außer
ihm an